will be a quarter finalist it would seem
only 13 minutes remain in the overall
match clock and with the score a seven
point lead for magnets he would have to
lose every game and lose some pretty
quickly for a bit to be able to mount a
comeback it's mathematically possible
Magnus is certainly not planning
to take his foot off the gas pedal
moreover he his openings are becoming
more and more combative as he trots out
a benoni but only one of the best bullet
openings because it's so easy to play
there's so many tactical ideas and the
main idea of course is to prepare B6 B5
but you always have to watch out for the
health of your D6 spawn this is the main
drawback Robert of the benoni this major
major long-term weakness on D6
that's a hundred percent the case and
that's why black first but a rook today
to protect upon now the Queen's over on
B7 B5 is next so did it went G4 that
might expose his King I don't see what's
next for that g-pawn and I clearly see
what Magnus has in Sword for did it man
and once these pawns start to roll it's
like a roller coaster going down the
hill there is nothing in this world that
can stop those pawns from steamrolling
White on the queen side you're going to
see Magnus soon enough I think pushing
C4 creating a little envelope for his
Knight on C5 he knows all of these ideas
down pat and he's got 56 seconds on his
clock as he's doing that
more than double did its time an easier
position to play for black the a file
open and now under Black's control and
C3 anybody with B4 next give me a
protected passport
C3 bit it saying no no no you are not
going to support that passer
unfortunately for white that Bishop is
plenty uh to support C3 safely and now
Magnus is going after that pawn on B4
with everything that he's got
is he really gonna put his Rook on C4 oh
no oh no
that is sad for white you just can't
protect B4 that one little Pawn on B5
defends both rows if only you could
replace the queen on B3 with a pawn
that's true but what a fine by bit it
there he went Rook to A1 and why is this
so good for black
apparently there's a ridiculous tactic
that's never gonna happen with Knight
takes before if Magnus plays that move I
leave wait what's the point 1964 Knight
he played it
F3
and now Bishop D4 sets up the main
thread on G1 he's found that too and
Avid has to abandon the Knight
and that ends the combination
23. the queen has only one Escape square
and it's enough
Rook B2 and it's over
this was a masterpiece like we were
talking about how great some of the
other games were this one Sublime
that would have taken me 30 minutes and
there'd be absolutely no guarantee that
I would see that move Knight takes B4
are you kidding me